detrás de la sonrisa de jury vérettes se
esconde una sensación de frustración
dirige un batallón en el frente oriental
siguiendo las instrucciones sobre cómo
minar un puente pierde la paciencia con
los civiles que aún tienen que evacuar
las ciudades en el donbass
como los civiles son un problema siempre
hay que mirar alrededor verificar que no
haya nadie es un problema en toda
ucrania
este problema increíble bach mucho una
ciudad clave en la región de dones que
todavía están en manos de los ucranianos
pero es atacada intensamente por rusia
las evacuaciones continúan aunque para
algunos se trata de una larga decisión
se cree que entre el 30 y 50 por ciento
de la población permaneció en backup
muchos vienen a este centro para recibir
la ayuda
si es peligroso pero es mi hogar y
pienso que todo va a salir bien
soldados en el hospital relatan la
batalla de rubín en una ciudad cercana
capturada por los rusos
letras muertas no pudimos usar la
artillería pesada porque había civiles
entre nosotros y los rusos habríamos
matado a nuestra gente
aplicados a skype que aquí está
otorgando mayores mientras los que
permanecen en terreno agradecen a los
voluntarios por instar a la gente a irse
tenemos que ser capaces de luchar pero
estamos asegurando que los civiles no
queden atrapados en la lucha y mueran
así perdemos batallas
en la ciudad vecina de severodonezk
alrededor de 12.000 civiles dicen estar
atrapados en medio de los combates